bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovi due sono un po vj oggi sono
felice
cioè all'apparenza ma dentro sto morendo
perché come aveva detto lo scorso video
oggi proverò a fare un episodio solo ed
esclusivamente p impossible però voglio
aggiungere una particolarità non solo
farò gli imposti col che sono è risaputo
ovviamente la categoria dei livelli più
difficili in assoluto di happiness
racconterò quanti in fossimo riuscirò a
fare in dieci minuti molto difficile
però che tante ragazze stiamo guardando
questo video ci siamo ragazzi timer
dieci minuti desktop e abbiamo
cominciato già sono partito malissimo
poi questo livello non si può fare è
impossibile quindi per partenza orribile
bike quanti impossible neanche un
neanche uno in dieci minuti secondo me
uno devo andare così tutto il video la
dedizione via via i senza tagli
devo centrali del buco no ma stai capi
ti prego si no staccati veloce che scade
madonna chi ammazza la madre non si
stacca dai bravissimo 2 perfetto veloce
veloce veloce questo siamo a 9 20 eventi
veloce tommy ci vai
orca davate sono vivo forse no vai
veloce velocissimo noi ci sono ma bolco
demonio ma lo voglio su mtv soddisfare
un miliardo di azioni
porca vacca ero partito bene la prima
volta buonissima col demonio questo
video sarà un riassunto di forza ma che
porco demonia prima hanno capito quanta
quanta roba non te ne prendi posso dire
e soprattutto visto che sono tutti
imposti perché devo fare in milano
secondo vai perfetto siamo a 3 da
riprodurre al naso are full vai
velocissimo 8 minuti e 40 dai come
faccio a far questo era una tattica
ottima quella di difendermi con questo
affare ma non so se mi fa infatti non mi
parlò con il personaggio nono gioco
veloce demonio tifoso è difficilissima
aspettato fare tv perfetto vai no ma non
puoi farlo story come faccio a fare il
suo livello ragazzi in barca vacca ma
non puoi questo buonissimo no sono morto
niente ragazzino studiarmi questo
livello come faccio con il padre di uk è
veramente impossibile non puoi uscire
vivo da stowe livello come fai a finirlo
dai dai
non sono morto porca vacca potevo essere
d'aiuto per una volta buonissimo
perfetto 44 livelli veloce veloce veloce
veloce
ok perché questo comunque uno spike col
brano spyphone imposti così buonissimo
dai sono vivo non è vero mi si è
aggrappato l'intestino
questo è veramente impossibile ragazzi
se lo faccio con la bici e poi con il
suicidio però attenzione non ho tempo
perché viene personaggi quindi ci credo
va bene l'impossible d'hiv devo passare
dove dunque cosa c'è di imposto con il
suo livello
ma dai se sfiga
dovevo entrare lì dentro sull'uscita
sbagliarlo vabbè ma non puoi
sopravvivere il suo livello noi invece
sì però non è un impulsivo normale
quindi l'atteso salto perso tempo perché
non c'è il traguardo
eccoli in posti così sono questi alcuni
si chiamano impossibile ma non sono
realmente l'impossible tipo call di
prima come ho fatto così dai neanche se
cipro 1 milione di volte però questo
riesco a farlo così guardate c'è la mina
la vedo
va bene prendere anche call call cosa
non fa niente
va bene come è finito sto livello non lo
saprei descrivere però va bene sei
finisce impossible finish detersivo va
bene trovai avanti schifoso laico feroce
ruolo non ci credo
no maledizione lui uscita fra una roba
incredibile sulla rambla bellissimo 76
minuti rimanenti almeno dieci al mio
obiettivo 1 al minuto e sta andando
molto bene ma quella cagata non ce la
farò mai più a fare un livello perfetto
7 questa è la 7 questa 7 by veloce
veloce veloce lascio il prossimo lei ma
edizione e come faccio
ma mi stacco nova che mia madre mi ha
attaccato
non puoi cambiare personaggio devo
spingermi così eh vabbè allora muori se
va beh mi sto spingendo questo non lo
posso fare 7 dai dai dai 5 minuti cinque
minuti per farne almeno tre ce l'ha
dovrei fare è teoricamente bellissimo 88
fatti 99 per cento veloce veloce cinque
minuti rimanenti questa si può fumare il
sud e il tratto il creatore del gioco ha
scritto non so se è possibile c'è roba
veramente inguardabile
porca vacca è mai messo le mine ovunque
come dovrei riuscire dai ti prego sono
otto devo farne almeno due almeno due
per arriverà 10 mancano 4.43 buonissimo
madonna voto sotto perfetto cioè from e
pieri falso salto lo dico io buono
buonissimo non ce la farò non ce l'avrei
mai fatto se non avessi vinto adesso
guarda al 99 almeno uno almeno uno è che
mira a cava che almeno questa città in
qualcosa che sei besana sforzati di
dimagrire non quello l'altro bataille
dai devi morire malissimo 10 mancano 3
minuti e 54 minuti praticamente per fare
prove del sestriere a 20 che devo farne
altri 10 in cinque minuti
c'è in quattro quindi in meno dai cons
primo arriverà 20 per adesso 10 li ho
fatti quindi uno al minuto almeno lo
abbiamo fatto
11 paolo infossi ha provato a farlo voi
se riuscite sta roba veramente ragazzi
impossibile la sicuro chi stata la mina
così nella leva di torno
sarebbe stato figlio se si fossero
spaccati di azioni ma va bene anche così
benissimo 12 bye bye bye bye dolcissimo
92,6 a questo punto di prima va bene non
fa niente da questo l'ho già fatto
velino va bene questo qua questo l'ho
già fatto quindi non va bene porca vacca
mi sa che devo cambiare pagina
perché li ho fatti tutti questi sotto
non l'ho fatto nei fatti questo no dai
non so dove andare non so dovete andare
va benissimo ha dato più che quindi mi
ha spianato la strada 12 fatti quindi 13
non vuol dire niente 12 fatti quindi 13
nel senso 12 prima quindi siamo tra i
generi e non è né non riesco e non può
andare lì ok va bene va bene va bene
avere schiva tutto bravo 14 2 mammamia
impossibile devo cambiare pagina però di
fare vedevo devo veramente velocizzare i
due mi chiedevo fare sei per arrivare a
20 cena o per questo possibile come
forse aspetta ragazzi spiegato ragazzi
che no non mi sono aggrappato se mi
aggrappavo non è vero non è vero faccio
schifo la mia vita veramente puzza un
minuto e 46 ti prego dai e va benissimo
15 devo fare 5 in un minuto il non è
possibile però 3 impossible in uno va
bene il progetto va bene allora questo è
uno che a marchio forse riesco a fare
tutto in fretta forse ci arriva 18 1 è
fatto ok quindi siamo 16 dai ti prego
prego dai va bene non è vero devi
passarci merci sulle mine occhio 17 va
benissimo che casino 18 dove 18 torna
dopo avanti quei doveri non vedo lo vedo
il 18 non lo vedo porca vacca se avevo
fatto in un così incredibile dove il 18
12 al 18 è che ora è il terzo già
scritto 3 in 1 dov'è il tuo terzo porca
vacca non c'è mai mentito a ra qua sotto
ma va a cagare
era di impossibile trovarlo questo sta
dalla difficoltà tra in questo sony
vostro no sono stato il muro 32 secondi
veloce voglio 18 voglio al 18 e vabbè
dai nomi si è spaccato il vetro 25
secondi manco cadere giù ragazzi
veramente impossibile 20 secondi da
almeno diciottesimo almeno diciottesimo
almeno e raggiunge questo livello
impossibile a 10 9 86 18 avere una moto
[Musica]
ti prego no l'ho toccato però all 8
allora allora finito counter finito il
counter
guardate dove sta il mio poco guardando
vera dov'era il pogo dov'era non sono
serio adesso gli rivolgiamo replay di
word blade ora il poco vale poco
guardalo bene quadro benissimo a era
dentro era denso e sei tu che sei hai
fatto male il livello era dentro quindi
vale 19 va qua se mi fossi impigliato in
quel punto lì dell'impossibile
maledizione avrei vinto avrei fatto
venti ragazzi 19 in fossimo lì in dieci
minuti non male secondo me non è male 19
in dieci minuti sono tipo 30 secondi a
impossible
c'è veramente una roba che se è
progaming a livelli estremi credo
all'ultimo secondo l'ho toccato per me
ci siamo ragazzi spero che avete vi sia
piaciuto 19 impossibili in dieci minuti
ti sfido si sa mai
nel frattempo spero che mi sia piaciuto
lasciate un bel commento mi piace
iscriviti questo è forse l'unico dei
pochissimi video senza tagli che ho
fatto nella mia vita c'è forse l'unico
credo non so chi come selezioni bisogna
al momento mi piace iscrivetevi a
chiamare schiacciatela campanellina che
trovate vicino al basso iscriviti e noi
come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
mettetevi piace sto video lo merita
maledizione
beh ragazzi
[Musica]
ma